yesterday Hillary Clinton made the big
announcement we all knew is coming yeah
that's right yeah that's right she's
going to join the all-female cast of
ghostbusters
[Applause]
I'd love it if that had been her
announcement that everything that really
would have taken Washington by stoy yeah
this is interesting Hillary Clinton
released a video announcing her
candidacy for president featuring a gay
couple yeah to those cool yeah then an
hour later Bill Clinton watched a very
different video featuring
[Applause]
[Music]
keeps rewinding gusto I missing Hillary
Clinton is now driving from New York to
Iowa did you know that yeah she's in a
van she's driving from New York to Iowa
it's being called the least exciting
spring break trip in history the ones
happy about that people are already
trying to figure out what to call Bill
Clinton if Hillary is elected president
yeah so far the most popular choices are
the first man the first husband and that
naked guy running across the South Lawn
[Music]
is he running away I do I know I just
think he was running
I just think naked yeah and he's Ryan
cuz he's having a good time so I got
other big news Marco Rubio announced
he's running for president yeah
settle down look we've got to do a show
here and if you can't calm yourselves
we're gonna have to stop it now you know
no Marco Rubio is running for president
a little fun fact Marco Rubio's wife is
a former Miami Dolphin cheerleader yeah
in other words she knows how to generate
fake enthusiasm for someone who's not
going to win
it was in the news another fun fact it's
been reported that Florida Senator Marco
Rubio graduated high school with a two
point one grade point average yes or is
that's called in Florida graduating with
honors what else happened other big
stuff happening over the weekend
President Obama had a historic meeting
with Cuba's Raul Castro the two met yeah
very cool
yeah the two didn't plan to meet but you
never know who you're gonna bump into at
Coachella
[Applause]
I like to picture them crowd-surfing
past each other they're great this band
scientists have located the section in
the brain responsible for sarcasm yes
that's true that located essentially the
brain
yeah the scientists said isn't that just
the most important scientific way and
[Applause]
then I saw this I thought was
fascinating a new report came out
it says dogs can sniff out prostate
cancer with almost 98% accuracy they can
sniff out humans prostate cancer with
almost 98% accuracy yeah
the report also finds that cats can
sniff it out with a hundred percent
accuracy but they prefer to watch you
die
[Applause]
[Music]
is so true is so true just think that's
so true it's unbelievable
you